Speaker 1: So yesterday, I covered the blow
up during a Senate hearing between Republican
Senator Rand Paul and Dr. Anthony Fauci of
the NIH.
And during that hearing, Dr. Fauci told Senator
Rand Paul in no uncertain terms that Rand
Paul, quote, doesn't know what he's talking
about and that if anyone is lying there, it's
Rand Paul himself.
This apparently has so infuriated Rand Paul.
He's on tilt.
He's unhinged that Rand Paul now says he is
requesting a criminal referral against Dr.
Fauci for allegedly lying to Congress.
The intimidation that is being carried out
against scientists and against medical professionals
is completely appalling.
Take a look at this from a recent Rand Paul
appearance on Fox News, where he announced
this, which he seems to be announcing almost
like it's some kind of badge of honor that
he's willing to take this incredibly principled
step.
Speaker 2: You kicked off your questioning
of Dr. Fauci emphasizing federal law makes
lying to Congress a felony punishable by up
to five years in prison.
Is your belief based on the evidence, Senator,
that he lied before Congress and broke the
law?
Yes.
And I will be sending a letter to the Department
of Justice asking for a criminal referral
because he has lied to Congress.
Speaker 1: This is an absolutely ghastly and
dreadful direction for the country to go in,
and it's a very, very dangerous one.
Dr. Peter Hotez posted to his Twitter a link
to an essay from 1940 one by Wildomar Kemfert
called Science in the Totalitarian State.
And it reminds us that the targeting of scientists
and doctors has a really ugly history, in
particular in the 20th century.
Remember that Albert Einstein decided to go
to the US at the very end of nineteen thirty
two, eventually came to the United States
in nineteen thirty three and stayed because
of what was happening in Europe, including
with reference to the world of science and
attacks on science are simply a totalitarian
hallmark.
Now, I'm not saying Rand Paul is Hitler.
I'm not saying Rand Paul is Hitler.
You have to clarify these things.
Otherwise, I will be very much punished for
the next twenty four hours on Twitter.
This means that when we see scientists and
doctors under attack for doing their jobs,
it should really scare us.
Now, fortunately, the current Department of
Justice is unlikely to actually do anything
with this request from Rand Paul under Merrick
Garland.
But what would a William Barr Department of
Justice under Donald Trump have done or someone
like Trump have done in such a case?
It's still a stretch, but it's within the
realm of maybe they'd look at whether Dr.
Fauci should be charged with something.
And this is a really, really chilling proposition.
So in terms of the confrontation between Dr.
Fauci and Rand Paul that we looked at yesterday,
I'm glad that Dr. Fauci took off the kid gloves.
I'm glad Dr. Fauci called Rand Paul out Foushee.
He almost looked uncomfortable doing it.
It's not really his thing, but how else is
he supposed to deal with the just persistent
attacks on science and scientists, attacks
on his morality, attacks on his ethics, and
unfortunately, much the way that Trump had
this longer term effect on the coarsening
of political discourse that went beyond Trump's
presidency, the legitimization of attacks
on just basic science, you know, masks and
vaccines, for example.
It I fear, and it seems pretty clear that
that is going to be seen as a legitimate way
to attack science that the right doesn't like
for a long time.
This is it's very clear that this is now a
tool of the American right wing and they can
use it.
They can use as a cudgel.
Science is just opinion.
Scientists are just politicians.
You can ignore empirical statements that come
from the scientific method, just like you
can ignore one of your political opponents
opinion about abortion.
Right.
They are making these things equivalent.
It's not as I've said before, don't don't
hurt me.
I know this.
I say this often.
It's not about we disagree as to what the
facts are.
It's they don't understand what are facts,
what types of statements are facts and what
types of statements are opinions.
And it's not new in that, for example, with
climate change, they've been denials for a
long time for sure.
But the mask and the vaccine stuff and even
denying the basics of how coronavirus works
for a very long time.
And even now to some degree, that's more than
we can't yet say with certainty whether we
are damaging the planet long term like I think
we are.
But that's a different type of denialism.
That's denialism, but it's different than
the virus is fake or masks do nothing or the
vaccine harms you.
Or this was created as a bioweapon in a lab
and deliberately released the legitimization
of that degree of nonsense as being just as
valid as the science.
It's actually almost post-modern in a sense.
Think about that, because for postmodernism
has been a popular target of the right.
Now, I've criticized postmodernism as well,
but the way the right does it the right comes
out and says postmodernism is the Marxist
enemy.
Postmodernism leads you into any any notion
from whoever about anything is valuable to
all this different stuff.
They are essentially doing a form of that.
They are saying our opinion about what coronaviruses
should be held up is just as valid as what
doctors think.
Our harebrained conspiracy theories about
vaccination should be considered just as valid
and serious and legitimate as what medical
science says.
It's a form of postmodernism and post structuralism
in which they are engaged.
It's a total hypocrisy that shouldn't surprise
us, but it's also very, very dangerous.
And we should be glad that the Merrick Garland
Department of Justice, I can imagine, is going
to take even remotely seriously Rand Paul's
request for a criminal referral against Dr.
Anthony Fauci.